hey margaret hey adam hi hey guys this
is a hot show
i watched every episode and i want more
yes we love it we need season two
um so definitely one of my favorite
characters sasha always gives the best
advice
how refreshing was it for you to be on a
show that not only depicts
female friendships but marriage and sex
from a female perspective
it was so so refreshing to be a part of
this
show because it chose to show women in
all our pluralities how we show up we're
not just the mom we're not
just the wife we're not just the
psychology professor you know we contain
multitudes
and i was really excited that you were
going to be seeing that
not just through billy's story but also
through sasha's story you know and then
you
see how they differently come together
from those
you know parallel lives that they're
living and retain
that same level of care
and love and respect for each other that
they found
when they were grad students in the past
scenes and that you know they really
utilized to
charge through and tear up the new york
city
you know landscape
yeah no i loved it like every time you
know you
you were together um with sarah just
like your chemistry like everything was
so great
um speaking of chemistry adam uh what
was your reaction when you
read all those sex scenes uh
my reaction is uh my mom's gonna have to
close your eyes a fair bit that's
that honestly my initial reaction is
amazing and
and yeah i mean it's not really when you
read the title of the show and then you
start reading the script
like you know what you're about to get
into but not maybe not to the full
extent but you have a fair idea
yeah and i mean for you obviously this
show is directed by
women it's written mostly by women
definitely from the female perspective
what was your experience like shooting
such intimate scenes
the environment they created for us is
so incredibly safe
and you know with an intimacy
coordinator and uh
and everyone just had a voice in the
rehearsals and
it's just it was such a safe set
and and yeah i don't they
stacy our showrunner is like one of the
greatest ever i've worked with her
before and unreal
and and she gave me this opportunity on
her baby and and i just like
yeah it was such a great safe
uh beautiful set to be a part of for
sure
absolutely yeah and did you feel the
same way market
absolutely i mean my feeling is if
you're on a set and you get a direction
that's
can you put a little more tongue in it
and you don't blink twice and you're
just like yeah
gotta go it's because you've built that
kind of shorthand
and rapport through the rehearsal
process and through the trust process
that we had that it's
totally gucci you know what i mean yeah
i mean if you feel comfortable then yeah
i mean those things are awkward no
matter what but if there's that comfort
there you're like okay let's go there
yeah exactly definitely she needs more
tongue i completely agree
yeah let's do this um adam i was talking
to cc2 and she said that you didn't even
meet sarah beforehand that you guys met
for the first time on set
so did you feel that instant connection
with her
when we when i first met her i walked
into the makeup trailer and i bumped
into her and she was wearing like a
christmas sweater so i was rattled by
that because it was the end of february
so i was confused initially but you know
she's so cool and so awesome and then we
got along straight away and so
it turned stacey's witchy like that i
guess she she knew something was up but
yeah it was weird that we didn't do a
chemistry read for a show like this but
yeah it all sort of
it's worked out pretty well that's
amazing and when you watch those scenes
back are you like
okay yeah that really worked yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's
it it worked pretty well i think
let me tell you i watched those scenes
and i was like
oh that's what was happening when i was
announcing oh okay okay
so then yeah i want to know like aside
from like filming it and feeling
comfortable on set
margot how do you feel about those
scenes because i have to tell you i was
watching them and i was like oh that's
hot
oh yeah no my face was like my jaw was
on the floor the entire
season you know and and it's really
fun to see how different these people
are from the the characters that they're
playing you know
um but it's it's so wonderful that this
show has so many different
ways uh that sex is uh first off
shown but also interpreted you know it's
really about the
psychological journey of these
characters when you're seeing the sex
and
and also it's about the female sense of
pleasure
and desire so you're getting to see so
many different
versions of how we enjoy you know
being pleasured and so for me it was
such a
fun roller coaster watching all of it
yeah i can only imagine well adam you're
gonna have to um delete your mom's
netflix account if you don't want her to
watch this show because it's gonna be
huge
well i i hope you're right but you know
she's the most
bi supportive mother of all time so
she'll find a way to do she'll find a
way she'll hack into something i'm sure
amazing well congratulations on the show
guys so nice talking to you thank you
you